[Música]
un 30% de la población ucraniana
necesita comida el país que en tiempos
de paz era uno de los grandes
productores de trigo de todo el mundo
vive hoy una crisis alimentaria y
nuestras enviadas especiales se
investigaron este fenómeno
la guerra no es la única causa de la
falta de alimentos que impacta en todo
el mundo o factores climáticos como las
sequías afectan a varios países y en
irak la escasez de lluvias amenaza al
mercado agrícola y aumenta el precio de
sus productos
la violencia armada sigue sacudiendo de
eeuu al menos una persona murió este
domingo por disparos en una iglesia en
el sur de california el ataque se
produce luego de que el sábado un joven
asesinar a a 10 personas en un
supermercado de buffalo nueva solo
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
france 24 en español gracias por seguir
acompañándonos y santiago ahorita que
comenzamos con información sobre la
guerra en ucrania un país que en tiempos
de paz era uno de los más grandes
productores de trigo de todo el mundo
vive hoy la paradoja de que un 30 por
ciento de su población necesita comida y
nuestras semillas especiales irene
sabios y leticia álvarez investigaron
este fenómeno consecuencia directa de la
guerra
a las doce del mediodía de un día normal
y angélica estarían trabajando como
empleadas de una tienda de jarquín pero
ahora han perdido su trabajo no tienen
suficiente comida y los constantes
cortes de electricidad también complican
el cocinar dieta
teníamos trabajo y dinero vivíamos como
todos pero con la guerra esto es lo que
ha pasado de casi todo
angélica que como era tradicional barrio
de sal y cova explica que el acceso a
las ayudas no es fácil bueno hemos
violado el toque de queda desplazándonos
a las 4 de la mañana para registrarnos
en las listas pero esto no ha sido
ninguna garantía solo pocas veces hemos
conseguido algo que algún trozo de
pepino que cebolla el pan y pollo justo
polvo tono ucrania era el granero de
europa
solía abastecer de trigo al mundo pero
ahora tiene dificultades para alimentar
a toda su población muchos centros de
ayuda están colapsados según el programa
mundial de alimentos más de 10 millones
de personas necesitan comida en este
momento en ucrania pero sólo tres
misiones la están recibiendo el
resultado es este desesperación de hecho
organizaciones como el programa mundial
de alimentos están en el terreno pero el
alargamiento de la guerra el aumento de
los precios y la escasez de gasolina
siguen operando la situación y más
ciudades necesita ayuda como también
ocurre en sabor y yo no temo que la
situación empeorará más gente necesitará
ayuda nosotros estamos intentando hacer
lo mejor como humanitarios para
ayudarles porque esto está sobrepasando
a las administraciones locales la
sociedad civil las ong y el esfuerzo de
los voluntarios para ayudar al pueblo
ucraniano en medio de esta incertidumbre
la población que no dejó el país lucha
por su propia supervivencia
[Música]
y la escasez de agua está llegando
temprano este año y la sequía afectó a
varios países del planeta uno de ellos
es irak donde la falta de lluvias está
amenazando al mercado agrícola sumado a
esto la guerra en ucrania ha generado un
aumento en los costos de producción que
incrementa el precio de los alimentos el
informe es de melissa chávez rincón
un país golpeado por tres años de sequía
irak ha sufrido una caída drástica en
las reservas de agua según el ministerio
de agricultura están muy por debajo del
umbral crítico nuestros recursos
hídricos están debajo de lo normal y las
importaciones desde el río éufrates son
actualmente de un 30% más bajas de lo
que son en condiciones normales entonces
tenemos un déficit de reservas y de
importaciones guardaste no hay las
autoridades y los agricultores temen por
las cosechas de arroz ámbar una variedad
que es ampliamente utilizada para
preparar platos tradicionales para
sobrevivir estos cultivos deben estar
sumergidos por lo menos cuatro meses
hasta su cosecha si hay escasez de agua
pero se debe a la ausencia de una
planificación adecuada por parte del
ministerio y la ausencia de tecnologías
modernas para desarrollar los sistemas
de riego las cosechas de arroz drenan
cerca de 12 mil millones de metros
cúbicos de agua durante el periodo de
cultivo por esta razón este año el
ministerio de agricultura lo limitó y
pasó de 35.000 a sólo 1000 hectáreas el
país deberá optar por la importación a
pesar que la agricultura representa el
20 por ciento de los puestos trabajo a
nivel nacional a dónde vamos a ir qué
podemos hacer siempre hemos vivido en
esta tierra tengo más de 76 años desde
que era niño he estado cultivando arroz
verde
sólo conocemos el cultivo de arroz aquí
es la única fuente de subsistencia de
camps acción en la misma situación se
encuentran los agricultores de trigo
quienes han visto reducida sus cosechas
a la mitad a esta crisis se le suman las
consecuencias de la guerra en ucrania
que ha disparado los costos de
producción y como resultado los precios
de los alimentos dejando a todo el
mercado agrícola amenazado
y en otras noticias las autoridades de
eeuu investigan los motivos por los
cuales un adolescente asesinó a 10
personas en su mayoría afroamericanas el
sábado pasado en un supermercado de
buffalo en nueva york' según el
comisionado de policía de buffalo se
trata de un crimen de odio racista el
atacante se declaró no culpable de la
acusación de homicidio en primer grado
consternación en eeuu por el tiroteo en
buffalo el departamento de justicia hizo
saber que investigue el hecho como un
crimen de odio extremismo violento con
motivación racial y un acto de
supremacía blanca el presidente joe
biden se pronunció este domingo
debemos trabajar todos juntos para hacer
frente al odio que sigue siendo una
mancha en el alma de eeuu nuestros
corazones están afligidos una vez más
pero nuestra determinación nunca debe
flaquear el crimen ocurrió en la tarde
de este sábado cuando un joven de 18
años abrió fuego en un supermercado
dejando como saldo 10 fallecidos y tres
heridos 11 de las víctimas eran
afroamericanos
al lugar de los hechos llegaron decenas
de personas manifestando su pesar por el
crimen hechos simplemente eso duele
uruguay son bryn gwyn duda porque
alguien haría eso entre otros puntos las
autoridades investigan si el agresor es
el autor de un manifiesto de 180 páginas
en internet en el que se justifica la
matanza con motivos racistas asimismo el
comisionado de policía afirmó sin dar
detalles que en junio del año pasado el
tirador había sido detenido y sometido a
una evaluación mental durante un día y
medio tras formular amenazas en una
escuela secundaria por el hecho no se le
acusó formalmente y fue puesto en
libertad este domingo otro episodio de
violencia armada volvió a sacudir a eeuu
al menos una persona murió por disparos
perpetrados en una iglesia en el sur de
california es tiroteo fue perpetrado en
una iglesia presbiteriana en la ciudad
de laguna google dijeron desde el
departamento del sheriff del condado de
orange los agentes detuvieron a un
sospechoso y recuperaron un arma en el
lugar de los hechos
vamos con noticias de américa latina'
cuba aprobó este domingo su nuevo código
penal en medio de críticas por parte de
opositores y activistas que temen que
este nuevo código dificulte aún más la
libertad para protestar y el ejercicio
del periodismo libre en el aumenta en
los tipos delictivos a 37 y se endurecen
penas en esta línea por ejemplo cuatro
delitos conllevarán a partir de ahora la
pena de muerte
y el barco francés germinal llegó a
colombia con el objetivo de continuar
con la lucha contra el narcotráfico en
la región del caribe su presencia en
este país sudamericano se enmarca en la
operación multinacional naval orión y su
arribo se da precisamente en un momento
en que colombia sigue teniendo múltiples
pendientes en la lucha contra la
producción y exportación de
estupefacientes
94 metros de largo 14 metros de ancho y
un objetivo la lucha contra el
narcotráfico el barco francés germinal
llegó a la ciudad de cartagena en el mar
caribe no se pacte la valla estratégica
texto no propone esta alianza
estratégica es muy importante para
nosotros porque nos permite conocer
mejor los flujos marítimos que
estupefacientes que parten de colombia
el cronista también de colombia es el
primer productor de cocaína en el mundo
es una nación que lucha activamente
contra narcotráfico color en la cuota
física una parada más del buque que sólo
en 2021 decomisó cinco toneladas de
cocaína e interpeló a 13
narcotraficantes la alianza se enmarca
en la campaña naval orión una operación
multilateral liderada por colombia que
pretende acabar con el tráfico de
estupefacientes en la región del caribe
y que reconoce el narcotráfico como un
tema transnacional la cooperación entre
francia y colombia es parte de un de
otra fuerza multinacional en la que
están metidos un montón de actores y
francia en colombia son apenas uno de
apenas dos de los 41 países que están
vinculados la cooperación entre ambos
países no es algo nuevo los franceses
persiguen varios objetivos
sobre todo con su presencia del caribe y
en sus territorios de ultramar y es muy
interesante que francia se vinculen más
con colombia en todo lo que sea
seguridad porque a veces políticamente
ha habido ciertas diferencias el
germinal llega a colombia en medio de
varios pendientes en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico solo en 2021 la producción
potencial de cocaína aumentó en un 8%
según la onu y el paro armado llevado a
cabo por el clan del golfo que afectó a
casi un tercio del país expone el
poderío que siguen teniendo los grupos
narcotraficantes en el país regresamos
en breve con muchas más noticias sigan
en france 24
[Música]